was louie crying
i cried at top gun maverick i did i knew
it i knew it i can't believe how they
preserved this [ __ ] character and how
tom did yeah and brought him to i mean
as soon as it opens with the shots of
the aircraft carrier and that and that
burner
and the guys point and all that you're
like i can't believe they did this i
can't believe they did this did they
really do it and then you see maverick
with his older but still cool arms as
he's you know
on the thing
and you're like go man go this is so
[ __ ] good and then you meet the other
characters and you're like all right
let's get through this yeah like i'm the
tough girl i'm the guy that doesn't
really ever give it up i'm the guy who's
kind of i don't know what anybody's
doing you got to watch that for a while
and they keep cutting the maverick yeah
which means nothing but that first scene
in the bar because they're like it's
okay he's here it's okay he's here oh
maverick is here he's here he's it's for
me
so the young people are meeting these
characters that i hate but they're
mavericks it's okay jennifer connolly's
over here she's okay they cut to the two
of them constantly they they're it's not
important that they're listening to
these kids
it's important that you as a viewer see
them
when you're watching you yeah sorry i'm
interested that's all i'm done
when you're watching
or you know we're watching stand-up
you're like seeing if you could see
where this joke is going etc
when you're watching film is it like
that all the time i stop and go back all
the time and see how
why the cuts were what they were and
yeah and this is always always and you
can see why they did stuff they fixed so
you can tell they fixed something you
could tell they cut something here you
can tell they cut something out
it's an awkward transition
and you know
yeah i study l movies all the time that
way okay you're studying movies
obviously stand-up is exploding i'm
talking about earlier in your career
right yeah you
did you notice that there were like
certain stories
that just exploded
and what it was about like story that
we're so drawn to like why is it like
i don't know there's something just
about human beings why are we so engaged
by the story i can give somebody a hot
take or a hot premise or whatever but
the story is the impactful thing the
story is when everybody's sitting around
in a group and you're telling a thing
that happened everybody shuts down
that's right
movies stories is big it drives it grabs
your interest in it and then you relate
to it and you want to see what happens
and it's suspenseful when a movie is
about something like an issue it lays
there because you feel the way you feel
about a movie
and i'm out of an issue and maybe they
maybe they're on your side maybe they're
not but you're like
it's just laying there so these
political movies they don't they don't
grab a viewer but if you're watching a
story by the way you can get to an issue
by driving through the story and do you
think do you think hollywood has an
inflated sense of self or do you think
it is
uh because of how impactful certain
movies and stories are do you think
there are certain people in hollywood
they're going listen we're going to
change the course of american history
with this it's not it's not that's it's
not that uh high pollutant it's cynical
they a story works so they go let's do
that let's do that story they just keep
every story has a reverberating effect
on a bunch of movies so as somebody
comes up with a story nobody's quite
told before
and then it gets done again and again
and again everybody's just chasing yeah
they're just chasing other people's
stories around okay and some people are
actually good at some of those are okay
you know some b movies are actually you
know
good on that level
it's a rehash of some other thing and
they put a prettier face on it and you
know
you get and then you add style they have
a style of filmmaking and you get that
there's a are you a fan of the nolan's
at all i know this is like main stream
christopher nolan yeah
i mean i i don't get grabbed by those
sort of like this is time is twisty that
was very really weird but i almost feel
like
and maybe this is because i'm a fan of
of their work i almost feel like this is
they well christopher and jonathan his
brother jonathan writes it with him oh i
didn't even know that yeah but um
i i just i wonder if that's them like
trying to flex
their storytelling ability i do think
that those movies are sincerely
interested in what they're doing i don't
think they're like it doesn't show up to
you or
that's yeah it's not my thing but
they're good they're great movies and
some people absolutely if anybody loves
a movie it's a great movie what is the
best move you've ever seen
it's impossible to say that i don't
really know um
it's so many that there's a movie
this one's just popping my head like
hard times
is a movie everybody should see it's
charles bronson and james coburn
and it's just about a guy who's a
bare-knuckle
you know
uh brawler
where they go to like a factory and they
get two guys and they just and guys
throw money it's like a cockfight with
men yeah yeah and it's during the
depression and it's set in new orleans
and somehow they made new orleans they
shot it in the 60s looked like new
orleans during the depression and it's
funny as [ __ ] and it's strange and it's
beautiful and there's this just charles
bronson just fist fighting with dudes
long fistfight scenes with blood
everywhere
and they're it's super fun
great movie